vous pouvez faire passer comme message
aux jeunes filles qui vous regarde voilà
ce soit à ce que vous leur conseiller si
elles ont envie de vivre leur rêve de
faire cette aventure miss france je leur
conseille de le faire à 100% je pense
qu'il faut suivre ses rêves je crois
qu'on est dans une période de vie on a
la chance de pouvoir changer de voie
saisir plein d'opportunités saisis
parce qu'il ya plein de métiers
différents et que y'a plein de plein de
débouchés les attend non mais c'est
qu'il ya plein de voix et qu'on a le
droit de changer de carrière il vient
finalement pas pourquoi pas tenter
faites vous confiance tentée le moment
vous aurez pas de regrets si demain tout
s'arrête au moins vous dirais que
jusqu'à la dernière minute lors des
suivantes vous avez dit de faire un
message aux jeunes filles qui nous
regarde pas aux chroniqueurs mais c'est
sympa aussi de leurs fins
qu'est ce que vous apprendrez qu'est-ce
que vous appréhendez plus qu'est ce qui
vous fait le plus peur c'est quoi là ça
va être là ça va être à 200 à l'heure
maintenant le plus peur ouais c'est ça
ce que je sais pas de quoi demain sera
fait donc là serment une vie à l aveugle
mais en plus vous êtes alors vous allez
rester là en ile de france donc c'est
votre région donc c'est vrai quoi là
c'est un peu plus simple on bouge et
c'est vrai que pour moi c'est un peu
plus simple alors il rêvait proches et
ma famille qui sont pour être miss
france vous êtes célibataire oui
j'ai senti un petit j'ai senti
attention
vous êtes alimentaire oui peut-être sur
wii donc vous avez le droit de yom
pourquoi pour la france ces français
tous les suspects et les spectateurs qui
vont être ravis alors je précise qu' il
faut être célibataire selon l'état civil
pour miss france d'accord moi je suis
célibataire or l'état civil mais pour
l'instant c'est seulement l'état civil
alors j'aimerais que pour être le sens
pour une question on sait ce qui attend
miss france en une année moi j'ai trois
enfants et je peux vous dire que je
pleure à chaque fois que je claque la
porte de chez moi pour partir en voyage
parce que je peux pas emmener mes
enfants partout on demande aux jeunes
femmes qui s'inscrivent d'être non
mariés avoir d'enfant donc mes dents
dans le
vous avez peut-être quelqu'un chéri
alors vous avez droit de voilà vous a le
droit d'avoir quelqu'un à paris la
mariée bail était en bail avec un come
back séance et ce avec un k way droit en
tout cas des temps by wallet est là pas
du tout non mais je dirais alors j'ai
répondu très honnêtement cette question
c'est que je sais que ma maman il ya des
miss qui veulent pas forcément répondre
moi je dis je suis célibataire
maintenant je ne suis pas un coeur à
prendre je vient d'accueillir beaucoup
de français dans mon coeur c'est pas
forcément le temps pour quelqu'un qui a
travaillé déjà 6
ch me ce qui vous plaît pas du tout
quatre garçons